for my pick we're talking to new york
times culture writers that's wesley
morris and jenna wortham
they kick off the new season of their
hit podcast it's so good still
processing
by confronting purse perhaps the most
charged word in the english language
what do you think that is it's the
n-word
in their new episode they exports many
faces and talk about an instant
instance where wertham called morris the
n-word what
i remember absorbing it you did your
wesley thing when you're uncomfortable
which is you just bust it out into a
very inexplicable
long last that had no end for many
seconds
you just kept laughing well for the next
three or four days after that
i was like jenna called me the n-word
jenna called me the n-word but
it made me feel loved i have to say
[Laughter]
it's really crazy
jenna goes it's crazy and wesley a lot
of people go that's crazy
so jenna and wesley good to see you both
what did you mean wesley when you said
you felt loved
i mean i understand that it's a term of
endearment
among black people and it can be and
you know i don't use the word that's
this is what jenna and i talk about
but when she said it to me she didn't
say it to
judge me i mean she did but not not
because i'm black it was because i was
doing something ridiculous
and i i sat with it and i really i
understood what it was
and jenna loves me and that's what she
meant when she said it i always feel
guys this is a tiptoe through the tulips
conversation
because i didn't grow up in a house
where we could use it or say it
and and now it certainly is coming up
but wesley you said you make
reservations with your soul before you
even write about it
jenna you said when you were in college
you used it with friends because you
thought it was cool and it was nice to
be defiant
but now you don't use it it still seems
after all this time it's complicated for
both of you
jenna can you respond to that
of course also gail thank you so much
for having us we love you so much and
it's always an honor to be here
we love you you know i'm so glad you're
here
[Laughter]
yeah you know i think when i was younger
i you know i really
relished in the ownership of the word
and i didn't always understand
the power that i was wielding when i
used it and over the course of my life
right up into that incident with wesley
you know i understood that
not all black people are the same of
course we know that and i never wanted
to harm someone and i don't want to harm
wesley i love him
so much and so for me it was just such
an eye-opening moment
about the ways in which i had to
reconsider my usage of the word
and maybe even you know working it out
of my vocabulary
you said wesley that white people have
as much stake in this word as black
people do
yes explain yeah
well i mean i think that you know in
this
day and age i think everybody hears that
word pretty frequently
whether you're using it or whether
you're in an environment in which it's
in a song
and i think you know it's a white it's a
white word
and i think that you know one of the
things that we've run up against in the
last
couple of months is the question
of when it is quote okay for
white people to use it espec you know
particularly if they're not using it
in a racist way if they're using it in a
quote if they are
you know repeating a rap lyric um
whereas you know among many black people
and many people in general i think the
assumption is you just
never say that word if you if you're not
black
um and what jen and i talk about on the
show is that it's more complicated than
that yep
so so talk about that wesley because
what you hear a lot of white folks say
is well well i see
people use it in movies i hear it in
songs why can't i use this word
why would you want to use the word
i guess that's the question right
because they're singing the song wesley
yeah
they're singing the song
well i think that one of the things that
we have to really think about i mean
one of the things and that's what jen
and i are talking about in this episode
is
you know it is not it's settled among
black people that it's a word that we
use but i think that
you understanding the history of this
word and how it came to be acceptable to
use in hip-hop
for instance or among black people it's
been a journey
and it's not just something you can drop
into and run
you'll see morgan whalen when you when
you get caught
you know out here using that word what
happens and and
that i think will begin in education for
this particular white person
so then on that question of an education
what do we do
when a white person is caught using this
word every case is different
and jenna i'll throw this to you every
case is different and needs to be
treated on a case-by-case basis however
are there kind of guidelines or things
people should look at when deciding
what needs to happen after it comes out
i think accountability and personal
responsibility
are always good immediate go-to's i
think
people need to not expect to be forgiven
right in this country privilege black
forgiveness
over white accountability and i'm ready
for that balance to head more towards
white accountability
and i think people need to examine why
they feel ownership
why they feel entitlement to use that
word and like wesley said why would they
want to use it
knowing its legacy i mean that word is
tied
to black death that word is tied to
the history of slavery and enslavement
of black people in this country like
if you feel that strongly about that
word you have a deep
inner journey to go on as a white person
and i deeply recommend that anybody who
is listening to this and feels very
strongly about their
the ability to use that word re-watch
roots and then decide
you can all also use it as a teachable
moment for many people which is which is
exactly what i think is happening to
morgan wallen at this time
to really take a deep dive into what it
means in the pain that it caused and i i
do think there's redemption i hope so
yeah yeah i i hope so too
yeah i believe that could be the case
jenna and wesley it's really good to see
you both
can't wait for the oscars there will be
much to discuss
we'll talk to you again i'm sure yeah i
i'm very curious to see how that goes
too thank you gail all right see you
guys
see you guys bye-bye new episodes of i
love the title still processing
are released every thursday available at
new york times dot com or wherever you
like to get your podcast